hey guys and welcome back to the channel
sorry I haven't posted in a little bit
I've been out of town and as a result
I've been slacking a little bit as you
can see though I'm filming at night
hence the serial killer lights on the
back of my apartment and as a result I
want to get this over with so let's go
ahead and get into things all right so
today we're going to be talking about
content delivery networks or CDN so what
is the premise Behind These well
basically in a lot of modern web
applications or even mobile applications
we want to be serving St static content
now what I mean when I say static
content is any type of file where it's
basically written once and then you're
never modifying it again so that might
be something like music some video
footage a photo or even possibly HTML
files because that also needs to get
sped up so much like my nether regions
these files are extremely large and as a
result it is very important to us and
very useful to us to be able to speed up
how quickly they load it is very crucial
for the user experience so let's go
ahead ahead and quickly give ourselves a
little reminder about what caching does
for all of us even though I've said this
the last few videos you never know who's
watching which so caching especially in
the distributed setting is going to
allow us to get great speed UPS in terms
of our application performance both in
reads and writes in the case of cbn's
mostly going to be reads but this is
possible through faster data storage a
lot of caches will store things in
memory not necessarily the case for CDN
just because they're big files but what
is definitely the case for CDN
is closer data storage we're going to be
Distributing our caches geographically
and as a result I can be physically
closer to the CDN that's going to be
serving me content caches of course
though do have downsides to them they're
not just perfect mainly in the sense
that of course the more components that
we add to our system the more complexity
we have we have to keep track of where
everything is located in terms of the
files there will be more downtime of all
of our CDN nodes and of course cash
misses are slow if I try to read from a
CDN and the content's Not There would
have just been faster to go straight to
the database wherever I was storing that
static content originally so the main
kind of you know distinguishing factor
of a CDN is this part right here it is a
geographically distributed cache that is
used specifically for static content so
it's basically a subset of a distributed
cache so as you can see below I've got
my terrible drawing of the USA and
Canada because I don't even know what
Canada is shaped like and frankly I was
too lazy to look it up but the point
here is that Geographic assarting is
going to allow us to do the following if
we have the USA over here this is New
York this is you know let's say San
Francisco Chicago and then we've got
Canada maybe Toronto and Vancouver the
point is is that different people in
different places are likely going to be
viewing different content let's imagine
that I went ahead and started a magazine
such as the Sports Illustrated Swimsuit
Edition the people in New York and San
Francisco might have a preference for
the american ladies in the magazine but
the people in Canada the dirty Canadians
might like the Canadian girls and as a
result we would want to cach different
images in their CDN nodes so hopefully
that makes sense this gives us a little
bit of extra flexibility allows us to
make the most usage of our space so
another important distinction with cdns
is the concept of pushing versus pulling
so using our Sports Illustrated Swimsuit
Edition example once again we have our
magazine on the left here and this would
be an example of a push CDN where let's
say we know that every single month or
maybe every day even we're going to be
uploading some new content and that's
going to be the majority of what users
are looking at in that case we can
preemptively populate our CDM so it's
October 2023 when I'm filming this video
so what I could do if I were film or
creating you know the Sports Illustrated
magazine is I could take the images of
that months Edition and pre-populate
them into the CDN such that when I ask
for bikini picks they're already in
there and the CDN says this is good to
go I already have your back covered now
of course if I were to look for an older
picture I'd be out of luck but we do
know in this case that the majority of
the time I'm going to be looking at the
most recent photos now that works really
really well when we have the type of
content that we know is going to be
accessed in advance however sometimes it
is less obvious and so the example I'll
be using on the right is only fans only
fans has a lot of creators and it's
probably impossible for the only fans
you know platform or admins to know in
advance which content is going to be
most popular so in this case we can use
a pole-based approach and that's going
to look something like this we've got
someone over here and they're going to
say feet picks obviously I've been
selling a lot of those on only fans
recently they've been blowing up so this
is pretty realistic the CDN at this
point maybe I just posted them so it's
going to say no I don't actually have
these it's then going to have to proxy
itself to the server and say do you have
feed picks and keep in mind this is
actually not the worst thing a nice
thing about CDN is because they are
using you know basically data center
level Hardware the network switches they
have are faster and that connection
between the CDN and the actual
application server could potentially
even be faster even though there is
technically kind of like a man in the-
Middle Dynamic so once we go ahead and
you know connect to our server the
server is going to say okay well
obviously I have these I'm the source of
Truth CDN you can go populate yourself
so now the CDN has these pictures over
here it's going to return them to the
user and store them such that when
another user comes along and asks for
the same one the CDN already has those
pictures and comes back back so of
course the poll based system is very
good when you don't know in advance what
content is going to be most popular
other places where this is going to be
useful or places like Tik Tok YouTube
Twitter anything like that where you
just don't know in advance because
there's such a wealthy amount of content
so of course the one downside of a pole
based CDN is that we're going to have a
cash miss this is kind of inevitable but
again it is going to slow things
down Okay so let's quickly conclude our
cdns here so I can go to bed but
basically like I mentioned men the
defining factor of a CDN is that
geographic distribution and the fact
that generally speaking we're using it
to serve static content so this has a
bunch of pros and a couple of cons as
well of course it is going like any
other cache to reduce the load on our
actual application servers if every
single one of us tried to reach out to a
server for the image or file that we
were looking for that would be extra
load that could be used for certain
other requests since so many of these
are going to be duplicated we're better
off just caching that content of course
in addition this is going to be faster
this is kind of where the geographic
part comes in at least as far as I'm
aware not all cdns are necessarily going
to be storing stuff in memory because
these files can potentially be big and
as a result you wouldn't be able to
store as many of them because you're
just going to have less memory so a good
chunk of these might actually still be
storing things on disk but if they're
much closer to the user you're still
going to get a nice performance
Improvement another thing is that we can
actually have different stuff in every
single cache split by location maybe if
you have many images you can split it by
resolution uh audio bit rate anything
along those lines you know we can
actually vary the content there which is
super nice do some pre-processing on it
of course we do have added complexity um
you know I now have to keep track of the
fact that I have all of these extra
nodes they can go down what am I going
to do as far as a coordination service
goes do I know which nodes are actually
mine which are up which are down and of
course cash misses especially in a
pole-based CDN are going to be expensive
in a push based CDN you'll have cash
misses when you try to access content
that you know the site admins didn't
think would be there so for example you
know if I want to access uh August 2023
photos when October is the most recent
edition of my Sports Illustrated
magazine I'm probably going to get a
cash Miss and that's going to be a bit
slower so CDN keep in mind or typically
something you want to be Outsourcing
because otherwise you'd have to set up
all these nodes and all these different
places feel free to look at the docs for
things like aami and Cloud flare and
then of course in terms of what we're on
to next I want you guys to start
thinking about well you know
of course CDN are a cache and as a
result you can't always store all of
your data your static content in those
caches so if they're not in the cash
where would we actually be storing them
because in truth a typical database like
we've discussed in the past is not
necessarily the best answer anyways guys
hope you enjoyed this video hope it was
informative and I will see you in the
next one